e aí
e eu nunca vou esquecer do meu primeiro
grande amor eu conheci a verdade quando
eu tinha uns 15 anos no ensino médio a
gente falava todos os dias ouvir as
mesmas músicas de uma visão de mundo
muito parecida acho que a gente ficou
umas duas vezes só mas foi suficiente
para ver apaixonar por ela e ela bom
fernanda começou a namorar o menino da
sala do lado logo depois que a gente
ficou eu consegui o bairro para superar
esse garoto os anos depois algumas
histórias tinham acontecido a gente
tinha se encontrado que eu sem querer
uma festa gente ficou mais uma vez eu
aproveitei aquele momento para poder
concentrado que você tira fica como é
que foi acompanhar o amor dela como é
que foi passar aqueles anos tenha ela
olhou nos meus olhos e disse serve o que
significou tudo isso para você bom por
razões óbvias a gente nunca mais teve
nada os anos depois já tava grupo que já
estava namorando um menino super legal
para gente boa divertido que me fazer
isso também mas
eu tinha acabado para mim eu lembro que
a gente foi jantar no meu restaurante
preferido e a gente marcou de conversar
logo ver forte chegando lá eu falei um
monte chorei um monte ele fez questão de
me levar em casa depois do fim quando
ele chegou na porta de casa e para o que
ela vai tirar aquelas fotos de cabine
fotográfica da mochila que a gente tinha
tirado uma festa corpo todo meio e tá eu
disse é para você não esquecer de mim
e estes foram as primeiras coisas em que
eu tomei um pé na bunda e eu tive que
terminar com alguém e mesmo com enredo
diferente com pessoas diferentes em
épocas bem distintas da minha vida não
foi fácil que nenhum filme é fácil a
escritora martha medeiros comparar o fim
de um relacionamento a sobreviver a uma
queda de avião por um seguros ninguém
fala ninguém se move todos em choque não
se sabe o que aconteceu mas status que é
grave alguma coisa que existir não
existe matos e é justamente este o
problema não é que acaba e pronto você
não se despede vai dormir quando acorda
tudo que lembrava que é uma pessoa não
existe mates pelo contrário geralmente a
gente precisa começar a lidar com
sentimentos desagradáveis que não
existiam naquela relação até agora a
gente precisa lidar com isso sozinho
pessoa que corresponde a outra ponta ver
se a vó não está mais ali esse momento
de paz noite de amor sempre me intrigou
muito que minha o finn é igual
é bem os meus e os meus amigos também
que eu escrevi um livro inteirinho sobre
o período depois do fim deve ser uma
pessoa escolheu uma histórias escreve
sua prometem que a gente termina o amor
até o momento que a gente se pergunta se
realmente superam mais curioso é que
quando as pessoas vão comprar o meu
livro todas elas falavam tudo bem é um
tendo sobre que ele fala mas esse livro
vai me fazer esquecer daquela pessoa a
gente lida com o fim de um
relacionamento de maneira muito parecida
porque a gente lida com a morte da
psicologia diz que todo luto inclusive o
afetivo o pastor cinco estágios são eles
a negação raiva barganha depressão e
aceitação algumas pessoas passam várias
vezes por esse estágios outras passam
por outro antes tem gente que passa
várias várias vezes por todos vezes até
finalmente superar o amor a bióloga é
ficha que estuda os efeitos do álcool no
cérebro associa está num relacionamento
as sensações prazerosas como uma vez
um relacionamento feliz apaixonado o
cérebro produz mais endorfinas faz com
que a gente sinta quase 50 positivas
pode existe uma ruptura de esse essa
ligação acaba a produção de endorfina
cai fazendo o que a gente sinta mais
infeliz e apática além disso sentimentos
como rejeição angústia do também
aparecem que fazem com que a gente tenha
que lidar com o fim do amor de uma
maneira muito peculiar o ato de esquecer
alguém como as pessoas que compram o meu
livro querem tanto eu levo a resposta
definidas do luto mas acaba se tornando
uma grande necessidade das pessoas
desejam de todas as formas apagar o que
elas sentem ou sentiram por alguém que
não está mais ali é quase como se elas
quiserem participar do experimento do
filme brilho eterno de uma mente sem
lembranças então tratamento inventado
para pagar memória seletiva as pessoas
que querem esquecer as outras
a gente realmente pudesse fazer isso
isso a gente pudesse esquecer
completamente de um amor que acabou
assim como confio um esqueci alguém
entrar em grandes efeitos colaterais
para quem escolhe fazer isso eu não
seria apenas apagar as lembranças da
outra pessoa da nossa vida imagina não
só se esquecer das datas de aniversários
dos telefones mas também esquecer de
tudo que você viveu naquele período não
se trata apenas de apagar algumas fotos
das redes sociais seria o mesmo que
apagar algumas vezes eu anos da nossa
existência seria o mesmo que apagar a
gente mesmo assim existe uma pressão
enorme de tirar aquela pessoa nesse
lugar que ela por uma pressão que vem de
dentro e que ignora que essas
providências são necessárias para
construir a nossa memória afetiva a
memória afetiva é responsável pela
social objeto sensações a lembranças um
perfume história muito mais do que são
cheiro vai sempre lembrar uma pessoa o
prato do seu restaurante preferido pra
lembrar daquele dia que você saiu
correndo para o hospital sempre me
toxicação alimentar
é uma música tocada que surpresa numa
festa vai te fazer correr para casa
chorar porque te lembra alguém e todas
as memórias são importantes para criar
as referências que a gente leva para os
próximos relacionamentos para além do
sentimento de perda luta afetivo é um
processo doloroso não só que a gente tem
que passar por ele várias várias vezes
na vida mas porque ele acontece de
maneira diferente com amor e diferentes
e o que sempre vai sobrar de cada um
desses processos é a gente ficamos nós
tudo que a gente aprende a mãe eu tirar
nas pessoas ficam os traumas que a gente
precisa aprender enfrentar para ajudar o
coração partido a seguir fica
necessidade do tempo e do outro cuidado
para entender quem nós somos e que nós
vamos ser depois que são pessoas sai da
nossa vida mas acima de tudo eu fico uma
pessoa que já passou próprios finge de
mudo e sobreviveu alguém que acordou no
dia seguinte mesmo com toda a dor
percebeu que a vida continua depois no
fim ficou espaço enorme em branco
esperando para ser preencher isso só é
possível quando a gente
é tudo o que aconteceu aconteceu sim mas
acabou teve amor ele faz esse amostra
sua mãe ou uma outra coisa alguma outra
coisa que vai ficar bom conhecida até a
chegada de novo amor ou de uma segunda
chance um sentimento que precisa ser
internalizado para a gente entender que
a vida não precisa ser vivido à noite
mas pode se a gente quiser mesmo comida
mesmo sabendo que tudo pode chegar ao
fim depois do fim fico processo inteiro
que cada um de nós precisa de idade mas
não era diferente e resta esperar que
esse processo evolua para que a gente
não precisa mais pensava que fica depois
do fim mas sim no universo de
possibilidades que existem no novo
comércio